i'm shine mahanti i'm the ceo and
co-founder of watchful and
we're building what we call the machine
teaching platform for the enterprise
now
today i'm going to be talking about
why hand labeling sucks
and what we can do to make it suck a
little less
so
let's talk about like why even label so
i think this is going to be review for
most people here but
when we talk about ai in the enterprise
we're generally talking about supervised
machine learning which
i'm going to paint with a really broad
brush here but we're generally talking
about algorithms that learn from
examples so you give it enough examples
of how to do a thing it learns how to do
that thing
so as a result labeled data is necessary
for training really any type of
supervised model and in general this
data is labeled by hand typically by an
army of humans that's recruited in some
capacity or outsourced to
and they're given the raw data and they
hand you back label data
now this works fairly well in any
situation where like context
isn't really necessary or
you know instructions are fairly clear
and things like that or if the volume of
the data is low or if the sensitivity of
the data is low
but this also feels really archaic like
you're doing all this crazy optimization
and sort of like automation downstream
of this why is
practically the most important part of
this all done manually
um
and and i think most data scientists in
this room is sort of a hot take i think
people here have probably either heard
or used the term ground truth uh to
refer to data labeled by a human but but
consider this like
what happens when these humans disagree
with one another
how do you determine what truth actually
is
and if you wanted to be able to repeat
this labeling process and get
deterministic results
how would you have to design that system
so
there are
several problems introduced by hand
labeling and the ones i talked about
already are part of them but
in general we can kind of like bucket
them into three categories firstly
data labeled by hand is inherently
biased prone
they're compounding effects here ranging
from humans just being human
and bringing their biases to the table
all the way to the fact that
hand labels can't be audited or
reproduced
and most high impact models those that
really move the needle for a particular
company or those that are you know of a
particular specialty
tend to rely very heavily on subject
matter expertise in the labeling process
for example any model that augments
doctors or lawyers should probably be
trained on data that was output by
doctors and lawyers
but these models don't end up getting
built a lot of the time because it's
cost prohibitive to even get started
imagine collecting an army of doctors to
just label a bunch of data like it would
be crazy expensive
as you increase the number of people who
review a thing you also increase the
likelihood that they're going to
disagree about that thing
so labeling teams usually cast these
complex relationships aside or try to
collapse into a single categorical label
which really loses the rich shades of
gray introduced by those disagreements
and fundamentally
humans are just valuable
so considering their output ground truth
is
irresponsible at best and kind of
dangerous at worst depending on the use
case
now
this
sort of diagram is meant to show that
bias can really start anywhere in an ml
system uh there are two distinct
families of bias shown here
uh those that are
data centric and those that are modeling
centric
data centric biases
are some of the hardest to combat
due in large part to the
irreproducibility of labels for the data
measurement bias for instance happens at
the labeling stage where the label is an
oversimplification of a much more
complex concept
for example think about like credit
worthiness how would you define credit
worthiness to just an army of people
labels end up being applied
inconsistently across labelers simply
because it's really difficult
to like fully and deterministically
articulate the concept of credit credit
worthiness to that group of people
but there are also several other vectors
for bias to be introduced here which all
affect the labeling process directly for
example
representation bias is where data is
sampled inconsistently for labeling
for example mortgage applications of a
certain type are selected for labeling
disproportionately more and frequently
than other types
and of course there's you know things
like historical bias where labelers are
bringing their like stereotypes their
their you know their bias to the table
um and really just reinforce opinions
that may not be in line with real life
one of the critical issues facing data
centric bias is the fact that labels
can't re reliably be reproduced or
explained
concretely there are a wide number of
reasons why a labeler might apply a bad
label um you know ultimately humans are
fallible uh it could be a simple mistake
like they retired and clicked the wrong
button uh or something more complex like
the labeling concept was ill-defined or
they were acting on a bias that they
weren't even aware of
if it was a mistake
by definition it's difficult
to reproduce those labels you know for
example showing the same labeler
the same row or the same piece of data
won't necessarily yield the same label
if the labeling constant was ill-defined
again it would be really difficult to
reproduce the labels as there's no
guarantee of consistency
across individual labelers let alone a
group of them and as a side effect it's
extremely difficult to narrow in on the
specific types of bias being introduced
and therefore it's really difficult to
figure out solutions for that bias
now
there's recently been a huge focus on
explainable ai to combat some of these
sources of bias but
a lot of these techniques only answer
part of the problem
a lot of explainable ai is centered
around like feature importance for
instance or statistical measures on the
data which really only tell part of the
story
for instance if we're building a model
to classify the creditworthiness of
applicants
we could use feature important
feature importance measures to determine
potential sources of bias in our data
but the bias could actually be encoded
at a level higher than explicit features
in our data it could be across latent
features which will be much more
difficult to pin down
as another concrete example let's say we
built and deployed a model that does
fraud detection
and at the time that we deployed the
model
let's say that
we are the experts on fraud and we
labeled all the data ourselves and we
know that this model
was trained on data that indicated two
percent of the total volume was fraud
and we know that that data was
representative of of real life
we put that model into production the
model says okay yeah two percent of the
data i'm seeing is fraud and we walk
away we do some other things we come
back a quarter later and we discover
that our model is now telling us that 20
of the data it's seeing is fraud
what happened
is it that the world shifted out from
under us and now the model is predicting
incorrectly or is it that we're actually
seeing an unprecedented
10x increase in the total amount of
fraud cases we actually don't know
unless
we take a look at what the model is
doing and compare it to what it should
be doing which is again a labeling
problem
so the only way we can really know these
things is by digging in and expending
human energy essentially calories on
applying human knowledge subject matter
expertise to the data and seeing where
the model lines up or doesn't
and again it's fundamentally hard if not
impossible to get real ground truth in
situations that require human
interpretation which makes this whole
problem that much more complex
now
fret not
there are several
potential solutions to this
think of this more like a survey
there are lots of different alternatives
to hand labeling
now i'm going to start furthest to the
left you know the things that require
the least amount of supervision but
take like machine teaching for example
machine teaching is a school of machine
learning that focuses on the extraction
of human knowledge from experts into a
form that models can use to learn from
it's a sort of like umbrella concept
that lots of techniques like weak
supervision fall under
and it's a useful reframing of typical
machine learning problems where
there's an overemphasis on the learner
or creating
the best algorithmic student and instead
machine teaching focuses on how to make
the teacher or the human in the loop
several orders of magnitude more
efficient
weak supervision is a technique where
functions or programs noisily indicate
potential labels
which are then aggregated and use the
supervision for downstream machine
learning models
this technique in particular has been
gaining a lot of popularity as it
doesn't require any hand labeled data at
all
though the technique is actually quite
hard to reason about a lot of the time
like what is a good heuristic in a world
where again you don't have ground truth
or in a world where you expect that
there's going to be noise what happens
when heuristics overlap what happens
when they conflict like how do you
reason about those relationships it's a
non-trivial problem
now on the exact opposite end of the
spectrum
you have the really really high
degrees of supervision system so you
have things like synthetic data
generators that may require large
quantities of data up front before
they're able to output sufficiently
useful data
these algorithms model the distribution
of a data set in order to generate
examples stemming from the distribution
and the generated examples aim to have
the same statistical validity as the
real data
now
there are caveats here if the real data
is extremely complex which in many real
world cases it is
it's really difficult to have enough
data to train an efficient synthetic
model and i'll talk a little bit more
about this uh in a little bit but
just know that they're caveats when you
get further and further down into the
supervision space as well as on the
really really low amounts of supervision
there's reasons why you'd use one over
the other
now transfer learning on the other hand
promises reduced reliance on label data
to achieve really high quality results
but in practice
if your task is extremely specific
for example if you're like fine-tuning
bert on a medical use case
you might still require a fair amount of
labeled data before you actually achieve
level of performance desired
finally semi-supervised learning and by
extension active learning promise kind
of like a middle ground
they have reduced reliance on hand
labeling and really they focus a lot of
their effort on keeping
the humans engaged at the level of just
like annotating one data point at a time
but they focus their time on the right
data points
and that's interesting because it kind
of feels like the best of both worlds
but
again it really comes down to like what
is your distribution in your actual
problem space and again we'll talk about
this in just a second
so a second's up let's talk about it um
the distribution of a problem is
extremely important so these
images uh kind of show
the distribution of problems that are
fairly common um and and they're they're
across several popular ai research data
sets um
basically it's showing the frequency of
model classes
and
these images indicate that in a lot of
these cases
the vast majority of the data actually
ends up on the tail of the distribution
so they're rare instances of a class as
opposed to the head where it's there's a
lot of like similarity
typically in like purely supervised
methods
they perform really well on common
inputs like in the head of a
distribution but start to struggle where
examples are sparse like in the tail
and i think most people here probably
already know that
but ignoring the tail can be equally
painful
you could end up with a bad model which
yields poor economics or
poor user experiences and and things
like that or some combination of the two
and when thinking about labeling data
like this it's important to consider
that humans are actually uniquely
equipped
to deal with problems on the long tail
you know that's what we excel at we can
take a rare case and we can just look at
it and be like oh that's clearly class x
whereas models have a harder time of
doing that
so it's important to consider just how
long tailed your problem is before
aligning on techniques for automating
the process of arriving at that label
data
for instance those problems that skew
really heavily towards long tails
may not fit an approach like synthetic
data generation
on the other hand a hybrid approach
might be good between you know some
higher supervision techniques and some
lower supervision techniques along with
manual annotation in a smart way
so you kind of have to like
balance exactly what your distribution
might look like and
kind of implement things from there
as i mentioned before
there is a growing area of weak
supervision in which subject matter
experts specify heuristics that the
system can use to make inferences about
unlabeled data
as an example
i could write a heuristic that says if
an email mentions prescription drugs
it is very likely spam
this would be noisy some percentage of
the time but my doctor might decide to
email me about my my my prescriptions
and uh
you know that wouldn't be spam but this
would still be strictly better than cla
better than random at classifying
for certain types of spam often times
however these heuristics are
insufficiently intelligent
adversarial agents like spammers
might catch on to some of the patterns
that i'm using
and change tact so for instance they
might add
invisible unicode characters or symbols
or spaces and and so on
now
i could train small models on these
slices of data or introduce fuzziness to
my heuristics in other ways but i will
usually end up with less interpretable
heuristics than if i just kept the
simpler versions
and this can be really expensive in
cases like um like diagnostic imaging
for instance
where we may need generalizability in
our heuristics but where it's still
incredibly important for us to be able
to interpret why a particular label was
applied
these types of approaches might break
down or might be called into question
machine teaching again is an umbrella
term for techniques like weak
supervision and even active learning
where these approaches can can be
combined into a single workflow designed
to extract knowledge from the user as
quickly as possible
and again if you're interested in how
these things can be combined i'll be
talking all about it in the office hours
or you can ask me questions afterwards
um
now amidst kind of this like increasing
concern about model transparency we're
also seeing calls for algorithmic
auditing
as i mentioned before it's really hard
to pin down the why from a model's
output since bias could be introduced at
multiple points throughout the machine
learning workflow
common explainable ai techniques can
provide ways to calculate some parts of
the y
you know from from the modeling
perspective at least
but they inherently can't go into the
why for the data and that's actually
very very important
machine tech machine teaching techniques
like weak supervision
more directly in code expertise and
hence bias
as heuristics and functions
making it easier to evaluate where
labeling went awry and why
and when you encode your knowledge as
functions you can easily walk backwards
from a label
and assess
why it was even applied and how it could
be changed if needed
if bias is encoded
remedying it is as simple as editing a
function
that said pure weak supervision systems
are specifically good at dealing with
the head of a distribution but frankly
you're really bad at handling the tail
creating a new heuristic for each unique
instance of a class is cumbersome at
best and like strictly slower than hand
labeling it worse
on the other hand sub sampling parts of
the long tail and training models that
can generalize well
can be an effective strategy for
managing this downward pressure
but may sacrifice auditability so your
mileage may vary depending on the
constraints of your task
for instance you know how would you
audit an ensemble of several models
trained on various subsamples of a data
set and how would you detect and
mitigate bias introduced by one or more
of those models it's it becomes like
this cascading problem across your
ensemble which you need to deal with
intelligently if you're going to do this
so we've sort of been living in like
theory world and i talk i talked about
like the theoretical problems around
hand labeling let's make it concrete and
talk about like uh the societal time and
financial costs of hand labeling
so this is
a really really good book which i highly
recommend
called ghost work
so for context
most data labeling services operate
large armies of contractors out of
low-wage countries
you know while this keeps prices low for
consumers of their services
it creates a race to the bottom effect
on these wages and and subsequently
creates an underclass of people
performing these sorts of uh you know
kind of soul-sucking jobs
now
they termed this work
ghost work because you don't really see
these people and they're not technically
part of your organization
now some of these jobs are simple forms
to fill out or
images of cars or people or foods
but other times
these are content moderation roles where
these ghost workers are pushed to review
shocking content
a lot of companies that employ these
types of workers often think
i just need these people for a little
while until i'm able to automate this
function but much of the time that day
never comes
because high cognition long tail tasks
are notoriously difficult to fully
automate which things like content
moderation are
and this is precisely the problem
that's historically actually been the
problem since the industrial age
treating badly people who do the
contingent work that can't quite be
automated yet
companies tend to stop paying attention
to these people and their work
conditions
and this is sort of where we are right
now with many parts of the global
labeling workforce so again i highly
recommend reading marielle gray's
ghostwork which talks way more about
this particular topic i've got lots of
opinions about it but i've got other
things to talk about as well
um
let's talk about the
cost of time
that's probably the biggest one here
for high impact models
many times you can't use a pre-existing
labeling service it's just not possible
your data might be too sensitive or it
might require context that this
workforce doesn't have
you might need subject matter experts to
be involved in the labeling process
which quickly ends up bottlenecking the
entire workflow
the bandwidth and time of experts is by
far the scarcest resource in the
pipeline and as a scarce resource
much of the time it's not even available
for instance if you're doing like hot
dog not hot dog type work it's fairly
easy to farm out 10 000 labeled examples
to an army of humans on some crowd
management platform that's not a problem
but if you're doing if you're looking to
do something more specific like cancer
not cancer
now your army of humans must be
specialists
and not just physicians we're talking
about oncologists or radiologists folks
like that
now
let's imagine let's do like kind of a
thought experiment together let's
imagine that you have a hundred thousand
mri images
and you have a team of the world's best
radiologists and oncologists they are
able to look at
at an mri image and within a minute with
100 accuracy tell you if it's cancer or
not cancer no problem
you give them this data
and therefore all this data just has to
be reviewed reviewed once you know
everyone just looks at one image and is
able to give you 100 accuracy that means
that they're going to spend 100 000
minutes evaluating this data set and
labeling it
which is about 1 600
human hours
and if they're billing out at like a
thousand dollars an hour we're looking
at conservatively around like 1.5
million dollars before you get to your
first prototype model like that's cost
prohibitive for pretty much anyone
unless you're google
this is precisely the problem you know
these are the use cases that move the
needle for most companies these are the
things that move the bottom line but
they're cost prohibitive to even get
started
so
this also doesn't even account for any
iterations you might have to do again we
were living in a fairy tale land where
we assumed that all these you know
physicians were able to just annotate
things perfectly the first time but more
likely than not it requires several
iterations and each time you do this it
costs you know a significant amount of
money
and to add to this
data scientists are are subject matter
experts too the time it takes to analyze
and correct errors in labeling by data
scientists is also very expensive
which compounds this problem even more
so
in the labeling process and i think this
comes to a surprise to the surprise of
no one
the most expensive part of it is just
human time being spent
and this is a problem across every
vertical every single company in the
world has a set of problems that are
best
solved using ai or ml
and they're not doing it not because
they don't have the ai or ml skill set
but because they can't get the data in a
form that they can train those models
so for instance the medical space like
is this patient a good match for this
clinical trial or not
or is this tumor benign or malignant
right again
these are use cases where the data must
be labeled by experts and probably two
different types of experts in that case
or in finance is this transaction fraud
if so what kind and how do we know
is this clause talking about
indemnification in insurance is this
claim high risk is there anything in
this claim that's potentially fraudulent
again the use cases go on and on and
more generally
as dependence on expertise increases
so does the likelihood that limited
access to subject matter experts becomes
a bottleneck
now
in the cancer versus not cancer example
i talked about before i hand waved a
pretty big part of the problem
we assumed that
every doctor was 100 accurate all the
time
and
we know as humans that that's very
unlikely to be the case but
these nice people actually proved it
as i mentioned earlier in this talk in
the real world
there's often no such thing as ground
truth it just doesn't exist a lot of the
time unless it's self-evident in the
data
this paper evaluated 10 of the most
common data sets like imagenet mnist
imdb amazon reviews and others they
estimated an average error rate
of about 3.4 percent across the data
sets
which is huge i mean that means that
three out of 100 data points were
incorrectly labeled
imagenet is 14 million images which
means that roughly 450 000 of those
images have incorrect labels i mean
that's insane and these are like
the most prevalent data sets in the
world these are the data sets with the
most eyes on them and the most citations
throughout all academic literature
imagine what's happening in the data
sets of the average company
naturally the paper indicated that once
the labels were corrected overall model
performance increased substantially but
even finding these errors is a
non-trivial task
unless the labels themselves again are
explainable or reproducible
again as i've reiterated ad nauseam by
now in most cases ground truth doesn't
exist
the measurement of bias in machine
learning often focuses on model
performance across identity subgroups
you know
at least with respect to ground truth
labels
however these methods don't directly
measure the associations that a model
may have learned
for example between labels and identity
subgroups
in the absence of ground truth
practitioners have to investigate more
clever techniques to measure bias across
subgroups and associations within the
label space
so this particular paper proposes
normalized point wise mutual information
uh
they indicate that it's a promising
approach for doing just that where they
determine a statistical measure of
association
that is used to derive the degree to
which models have learned
stereotype-aligned associations
regarding sensitive identity labels so
they figure out the co-occurrence
between a particular identity identity
level and a negative outcome and they
determine if that's you know randomly
distributed normally distributed or
there seems to be a correlation that is
in line with a negative stereotype
and this is just like an interesting
thing that i found the other day
i happen to stumble upon this but
apparently distilbert loves movies
filmed in india but not in iraq
there's likely several things that are
happening here like um
you know there's potentially model bias
and that distilbert was designed in a
way where uh at least a sentiment
classifier can only classify into
positive or negative
there's no neutral class
so it has to predict sentiment on these
neutral statements which makes no sense
so this could be model bias for instance
on the other hand statements like
i tried like i was born in germany
that consistently yields a negative
sentiment
which is a very very interesting case
you know potentially of like biased
model reflection due significantly due
to significantly leaked bias built up in
the pre-training process um
so like even some of the most
scrutinized and widely used models in
the world have insane amounts of bias
so it's important to be able to like go
backwards and figure out why that bias
even existed
and again fret not there are lots of
different ways we can evaluate this um
i'm not going to go through every single
one of these
um
but i'll pick out a couple that i think
are worth mentioning the axis here
is scope of interpretation ranging from
local interpretation or those focused on
explaining specific predictions
uh to global interpretation or those you
know designed to explain entire models
or distributions
so
a couple of these examples are
counterfactual examples lime
global surrogate models and chap
those seem to be some of the more
up-and-coming and most widely used
explainability techniques these days at
least
now counterfactual explanations have
become popular recently where they
describe a causal situation in the form
of if x had not occurred y would not
have occurred
for example if i hadn't taken a sip of
this hot tea
i wouldn't have burned my tongue
event why is that i burned my tongue
cause x is that i had hot tea
in explainable machine learning
counterfactual examples can be used to
explain predictions of individual
instances
the event
is the predicted outcome of an instance
the causes are the particular feature
values of that instance
the counterfactual explanation of a
prediction describes the smallest change
to the future values
that changes the prediction to a to a
predefined output
lime produces similar types of
explanations at the level of individual
predictions but in a different way
lyme was actually born out of a paper
where the authors proposed a concrete
implementation of local surrogate models
which are interpretable models that are
used to explain individual predictions
of black box machine learning models so
in in the framework lime generates a new
data set consisting of
perturbed examples or perturbed samples
rather of a given data set and the
corresponding predictions of a black box
model and basically what happens is a
new interpretable model is trained on
this data and explanations are provided
which measures how close this
explanation is to the prediction of the
original model
global surrogate models takes this idea
and applies it to the entire black box
model itself as opposed to just applying
it to individual predictions
so surrogate models are interpretable
models that are trained to approximate
the predictions
of a more complex black box model
this technique is best used if an
outcome of interest is
expensive time consuming or otherwise
difficult to measure so if it costs you
like
a bunch of gpu time to inference against
your like behemoth neural net then it
might make sense for you to like train a
little decision tree that roughly
approximates it
a cheap fast surrogate model
of the outcome can be used instead to
approximate the predictions of the
underlying model as accurately as
possible and to be interpretable at the
same time
and shap was proposed in 2016 as a
method to explain individual predictions
using techniques from game theory while
still being extensible to
global model explanations
so in shap
the feature values of a data point act
as players in a coalition
where shapley values tell tell us how to
fairly distribute the prediction among
the features
the shaft framework connects lime and
shapley values and has a fast
implementation for tree based models
this makes it possible to compute the
many shapley values necessary for a
global model interpretation which
includes feature importance feature
dependence
interactions clustering and summary
plots and and so on
there are tons of options here and it
really comes down to what types of
techniques you are choosing to be your
quote unquote productivity engine in a
given machine learning system
for instance if you choose simpler
modeling techniques to drive your label
predictions you can use techniques like
shap as a performant way to explain
these predictions
and to provide information to the user
for iteration
on the other hand if you choose more
complex modeling techniques
it might be useful to consider other
ways to interpret these predictions like
using local or global surrogate models
so three things to kind of keep in mind
here
number one
you're never done labeling
every single time you put a model into
production you must assume that that
model will need to be retrained at some
point depending on your use case that
could be sooner rather than later for
other use cases it could be longer
concrete examples if you're training a
model to do something like fraud
detection or
if you're in the cyber security space
and you're trying to do intrusion
prevention or something like that you're
fighting against an adversary who is
incentivized to change your tactics
quickly the moment they are detected so
as a result you're gonna see drift
frequently this also happens in content
moderation where um the latest and
greatest like alt-right dog whistle will
show up all of a sudden and now you've
gotta like figure out why this benign
word is suddenly like seen as like crazy
racist
so that is a concept of drift that
happens more frequently than others as
opposed to something like the medical
field or the legal field where it moves
a little bit more slowly but there are
still cases where you might have an
acute event that causes a great shift
like with the pandemic
all of a sudden a bunch of assumptions
about
you know epidemiology had to be shifted
so this is just some examples of when
drift might occur and again you have to
assume that you're never done labeling
any model you put into production if
it's worth keeping it there you're going
to have to re like retrain at some point
which then means you have to relabel for
it
what's more is that class definitions
often change as labeling progresses i
don't know if anyone here has actually
tried sitting down labeling some data
but usually your first 10 labels
are going to be strictly worse than your
last 10
and that's just because you're
discovering the class as you go you know
you're
finding things out about the data you
don't have the full distribution in your
head until you start playing with it
and that's just an interesting concept
that means that
by nature the first like several minutes
or even hours of your labels
might be of strictly worse quality than
your last several minutes or hours and
that has effects on your model
and again the cost of subject matter
expertise
compounds the cost of the overall
pipeline
once again you're never done labeling
and as a result if you need subject
matter experts to be the labelers
then each and every time you retrain
your model you have to re-engage with
those experts and again you're eating
that cost over and over and over again
and it becomes just a fixed cost on this
like long running pipeline
now
in terms of performance because i think
that's an important thing to consider
here when you're thinking about
automation techniques
even if getting machines to label much
of your data really results in slightly
noisier labels
your models are often better off with 10
times as many slightly noisier labels
now i'm painting with like a wildly
broad brush here
this is super dependent on your model
architecture if you're training smaller
models you need less overall data and
therefore you'll see less benefit from
scaling training sets however if you're
training large data hungry models
you may see better performance training
those models on lots of data even if it
means sacrificing a few points of
accuracy precision recall
et cetera and the training data
both of these papers go on to prove that
depending on model architecture's
performance can be scaled
as training data sets become larger and
contain distributions represented
representative of the production data
flow
model performance tends to increase as
well
so the key question isn't should i hand
label my training data or should i label
it programmatically
really the question to be asked is which
parts of my data should i hand label and
which parts should i label
programmatically
specifically focusing human effort on
the important parts of the long tail
while making programmatic gains on the
head
is a promising approach to solving a
fundamentally hard problem in every
supervised machine learning pipeline
and just to sort of wrap up here when
thinking about labeling strategies
consider the following
number one explainable labels are
important in being able to find and fix
issues downstream in the modeling
process
number two automation is important in
being able to scale subject matter
expert involvement in the labeling
process
and number three
probabilistic evaluation is important in
being able to accurately represent tasks
in the real world and what i mean by
that is again
there is no such thing as ground truth
so blindly categorizing things into
zeros and ones
will only hurt your model's performance
if it's not representative of what's
happening in the real world there are
cases most cases where there is
ambiguity and having that ambiguity is
part of the mod of the labeling process
will lead to better models because your
model is able to find a richer
relationship between the target value
and the input
there are tons of ways that you could
combine techniques we talked about today
to have these three properties naturally
i have lots of opinions on the optimal
combinations of these processes
and i'm happy to talk about them at
length in office hours today so yeah
that's it thank you so much
you